pour résumer simplement les choses
disons que d'une part leur eau à eux
était plus bas que le bas de ceux d'en
haut et que d'autre part leurs bas
étaient excessivement au dessus de leurs
eaux de sorte que quand un shadok d'en
bas voulait tomber d'assez haut par
exemple il fallait qu'ils sautent de
bien plus bas que si le haut avait été
nettement au dessous c'est à dire en
réalité au dessus du bas ou quelque
chose comme ça pour le reste c'était
pareil et pour partir il avait construit
devinez quoi une fusée évidemment mais à
l'envers
restait à savoir si une fusée comme ça
accepterait de marché à l'envers dans un
espace à l'endroit ou inversement